it's a move designed to boost the
unlocking of the economy
and halt the virus in its tracks
starting this friday
everyone in england will be offered two
free covid tests a week
at home or at work and in schools and
colleges
people will be able to order test kits
online
or collect them from pharmacies and the
tests will produce results in 30 minutes
the program which will cost billions is
aimed at people without symptoms
because one in three people with covid
don't have any
and may be spreading the virus
unwittingly
but the test won't be compulsory the
prime minister says
as we continue to make good progress on
our vaccine program
and with our roadmap to cautiously
easing restrictions underway
regular rapid testing is even more
important
to make sure those efforts are not
wasted
the really critical thing we don't know
is what effect it has
on transmission of coronavirus so the
liverpool
pilot of this happened at the same time
as lockdown
so the number of cases did go down but
we didn't have any comparison
to a no testing area so we
really don't know what contribution it
makes or doesn't make
the scheme has been announced ahead of a
downing street news conference this
afternoon
at which boris johnson will confirm that
the next stage of easing lockdown rules
in england
is on schedule today's statement by the
prime minister is the most
eagerly awaited on lockdown easing
measures
since he unveiled his roadmap to freedom
with its four
steps back in february step
two with hospitality opening outdoors
and non-essential retail reopening is
due
a week today also due to reopen next
week are gyms
which have been closed in england since
early january
we opened bookings hopefully tomorrow
we're just waiting for boris
to press the button we need now to get
people back
into exercise sort their physical health
out
sort their mental health out this
afternoon mr johnson will also describe
his plans for vaccine passports
for major events like wembley cup finals
and a traffic-like quarantine system for
overseas travellers
all in all it's one of the biggest days
so far
towards the lifting of restrictions john
craig sky news